Carroll is an Idaho our churches in the
process of planting a new church they're
trying to secure a loan for the building
and they ask the congregation to pray
about being co-signers on the loan I
feel this goes against the Bible
what do you think well the bottle is
very clear proverbs 1718 says 1 lacking
incense
co-signs for another and as a matter
fact if you look up the contemporary
English version the CEV it says one who
cosines for another is stupid that's
what the Bible says now so there you go
so yeah that's it's ridiculous it not
not only is it against what Scripture
teaches but it's stupid the Bible is
right and I'm certainly not co-signing a
loan for a church who handles their
money so poorly that they are planting a
church with no money that means it
operates poorly ok it doesn't mean that
churches shouldn't plant no they should
plant but there's lots of churches that
do Church plants with zero debt and they
do it all the time they start in a
school a high school auditorium or
something yeah you know they use the
lunchroom to meet and they get started
somewhere in a public facility of some
kind the YMCA or whatever on Sunday
mornings they use their meeting room and
get started lots of people plant
churches that are unbelievably
successful that way yes I did that in
order to plant a church you need to
borrow money to buy a building is pretty
absurd you need to understand that 97
percent of church plants fail yeah and
I've you know we're familiar with
several church organizations around we
know one that actually has a 95% success
ratio with their church plants as
opposed to a 97 percent failure rate
which is the average how do they do that
well I can't guarantee their own money
for a building they've got a detailed
system that includes all this financial
wisdom that is unbelievable and it
causes them to be able to plant and do
that properly so and if someone tells
you God told them to co-sign God told
them to borrow you can just say no he
didn't because God does not give advice
that's perpendicular to his word there
you go
I was just reading I was scanning
through the news stuff and I was just
reading that the women on the view said
that Mike Pence when he said he talks to
Jesus that's a sign of mental illness so
apparently a bunch of us have mental
illness but was it Joey
what's-her-name mayor or something I
can't I don't watch the view I don't
even know who's on it something like
that but yeah apparently those of us
they're people of faith that mental
illness according to the view
I'm very interesting you know but so
yeah but but I can tell you this the
Bible is pretty clear and if someone
says to you that you know I'll give you
an example okay one that many many years
ago I was coaching a young couple who
had an income of $1,500 a month
they had a car payment of $600 to little
kids their light bill was about to be
cut off their electric bills might be
cut off because they weren't paying it
they were behind on their rent and their
I'm going guys this car how this car is
nuts
this car is crazy you've got to sell
this car and the guy looks at me with
all seriousness he goes we cannot sell
that car God told us to buy that car and
I said no he didn't because you you know
what God told me and I said absolutely I
do
I know God did not tell you to buy that
car how do you know because the Bible
says the blessings of the Lord have no
sorrow added to them and you have two
little kids without food in the house
and the lights are getting ready be cut
off and they getting really homeless
because you bought a car you can't
afford this is not a blessing it's a
curse and
does not give you curses the blessings
of the Lord have no sorrow added to them
he goes well I the finance manager even
said it was a miracle and I said it is a
miracle you got this dadgum payment on
1,500 bucks income how do you get a six
hundred dollar payment on a fifteen
hundred dollar income you that that's a
miracle but it's not a miracle from God
it's just plain plain straight-up
subprime stupidity saw the car you think
I need to sell the car what am I saying
here you gotta sell the car you think I
need to sell the car yeah that or you
need to move into it because you can't I
mean that's just it's absurd so that's
that you know when something is that
perpendicular to Scripture
the blessings of the Lord have no sorrow
added to them let me tell you what's
gonna happen that church is gonna fail
because 97% of church plants fail and
when it does all you people that cosign
on that note are gonna have a bad church
experience and then you're gonna be mad
at God on it in God's fault that you're
stupid don't blame God